Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and ahhh
I am just checking in on you.
How the fuck are you? I don't have time.
I don't have time for your
fucking shit today. Yeah,
I got people coming in
town to see my dog. Right.
So I got a bunch of Shit I have to do.
You know, you know when you got family,
the folk and family, Becky,
we're having problems with your
family baggy sched what movie?
We have a Brabant with the family.
Baggaged the Vegas
fucking mafioso line ever.
I'm not going to say, you know, cause
I want to shit on the fucking writers.
I'm like shit on people that
I'm in this industry sort of.
That was the laziest fucking writing
ever. You see sort of a mob guy?
Yeah. Nah, they're having family
problems with the family back east.
How Far East you're in La.
Are you having problems
with the family in Nevada
and problems with the family baggy? Um,
I'm in construction. Oh, it's
not that movie. All right.
Anyways, it's not the one,
you think it was more
recent and they evidentaly
yeah.
From what I gathered from the writing
was they were having problems with the
family. Baggies, sorry, I'm going to
kill this thing here. Um, anyways,
you know, when you, when you got
fucking relatives coming out,
you know what the deal is? You got to
fucking clean your house up. You know,
you, you got to get all spiffy,
go out and get a haircut of you,
meet you shave it down,
right. You're looking at,
in my head how successful
I'm doing. Well, right.
You gotta track him to
all these fucking spots.
You got to try to
impress people, you know.
Okay.
Kinda hit me yesterday as I
was, I was scampering you know,
somebody don't do a lot
scampering something.
Usually a marsupial does
up a tree, I believe, um,
scamper around the house, just trying
to fucking make it look like I,
I don't live in a world of clutter.
And at one point I'm just saying, I,
you know, built, nobody
gives a shit about you.
Nobody is coming out to see you.
Nobody gives a fuck what you're doing.
It's all about your daughter.
And I was like, I was just great.
It's perfect. She's the
headliner. I'm just hosting. Hey,
how's everybody doing?
You want a burger? Boom.
Let's keep this show moving
right along. Put the act.
Y'All came here to seek my lovely
daughter. That's all I got to do.
All you have to do is host to show
those to show. As long as she's cute,
what she can help. As long as
she smiles, when she can help,
that's all she does is smile and laugh.
She's the fucking greatest kid ever.
I'll be fine. So there you go.
Why am I trying to do all
the dishes? It was funny.
All you really do, whenever you have
company over, you have like that, the,
that one fucking closet.
You throw everything in or maybe one
closet and every room you just take all of
all of the clutter and you
just throw it into the closet.
Like for some reason as this pressure
that your house has to look like,
you know, like a show room
at a furniture store. Like,
we don't have any knickknacks,
we are living a minimalist lifestyle.
Everything is neat and is in order.
Everything is in its proper place.
Harmony is what you're experiencing here.
We never fight is never
a look crossword, um,
day. He can't live up to it.
So I just decided I got to a certain
level of clean. I'm like, all right,
well this is what it looks like. You
know, what are you gonna do? Oh God,
I'm still nervous. Anyways. Um,
let's get down to the fucking
tax that are brass here. Um,
oh boy. The city of Washington
DC, the district of Columbia.
Oh, their morning today. Jesus Christ.
I actually went to a city Gab with Josh.
He had a mys and um, this is
how big a hockey fan I am.
The Celtics were playing the
wizard jested at game five.
I thought it was game six.
I got lost with all the sleep deprivation
from all cutie cakes downstairs.
Right. Um, and I actually,
we went in the cigar bar and we were
watching the game seven and in between
periods we would click in to the
Celtics. I know Bradley had a huge game.
I know that the wizards went up like
four to nothing and then that was it.
We gave him the old right there, Fred
and kept our foot on their neck. Right.
So that was the biggest night in
Washington d c sports perhaps ever.
I had fun cause I woke up
cause I was supposed to, um,
yesterday I woke up early by Doodoodoo
dude and I was supposed to call 'em a
Regina, Saskatchewan, cause I'm
going up there for some shows. Uh,
I don't know where the fuck I'm
going. I think I'm in Winnipeg.
And then I'm driving all the
way up to fucking Saskatoon,
which is like an eight and a half hour
drive and I'm doing it and everyone's
like, Oh you don't go bug the toy. Good
to put your farms. I don't give a shit.
I'm going to have a great time. He
and Nick Craig, we're going to go up,
there's gotta be some sort of ice cream
store of some fucking stupid tourist
attraction along the way. And even
if there isn't, who gives a shit?
I like driving that stuff.
Seen it, that it exists.
I did the drive one time from
California to El Paso, Texas, and, uh,
that's one of the great drives
over dead, especially I believe,
I don't know if it was in Arizona or
New Mexico when you just get into the
badlands. I always thought
the badlands meant, you know,
some Badass dudes live there and
it's just bad as far as like,
you can't grow anything
that's like scorched earth.
It's like basically the direction
we're headed in. If we keep fucking,
and I don't know if you
believe Al Gore, I mean,
I tend to believe a man who invented
the Internet, you know, anyways.
Um, so we're going to be doing that
drive. And uh, so I had to call,
cause they added,
they added another show in Regina
because who the fuck ever goes to
Saskatchewan? You know, nobody. So
people are excited. Like, Holy Shit,
this guy's not my favorite, but he
fucking showed up. Let's go. Right.
They and Brahms, we fear me baggies.
So they added a second show.
So now I gotta,
I gotta put on my top hat and my
tales and I gotta fucking sell it.
So I'm waiting to call the
radio. This is such a long story.
So I'm thinking in my head
right now, I'm like, wow,
this is the biggest day in
Washington DC sports history.
I should call the fucking sports
junkies. I'm going to do it. I called in,
talked to larch and everybody yet, uh, I
thought the capitals were going to win.
I just thought how badly
they beat the penguins
in a, in game six. I just
thought that they, uh,
they was shutting down their offense,
that the penguins were frustrated.
You know, I knew the fucking
flower they was going to have,
was going to have a good game,
but I just thought they just needed to
break the seal. They had to get that one,
give him a little bit of happy feet,
give him some to fucking think about it.
So I called in there,
then it called and Randy a Bauman
and bill Crawford at wd DV.
And uh, I wasn't a contact on either
one of them. My team side of it.
I'm not going to try to be a killjoy, you
know, I, this is the deal. I actually,
I don't know what happened. I
used to hate the fucking penguins.
I don't anymore. It's a combination
that they don't really have any,
like overtly cheap fucking
knee breakers anymore.
And I got a lot of friends that
either live in Pittsburgh or you know,
out here that are from them. Fucking
pardon me. I can't root against partners.
So I go to the cigar bar and I, uh,
I'm watching it with fucking Josh, Adam
Meyers, and he's just like, you know,
I said, look, dude, I'm not going to
lie to you. I hope you go one in one.
I want the Celtics to win and I'm
going to root for the capitals.
I'm sitting here with you. I'll
fucking root for them, you know,
secretly I'm like,
well, if they don't win,
I'm happy for fucking Randy Crawford
and partner. Can those guys, what,
what do I care? I'm, my
fucking team's not in it.
So we sit there and Josh
is fucking losing his shit.
And um, it was just
unbelievable. You know,
I call him the flower all the time.
I forget his fucking name already.
Mark Andre Flurry. What
a fucking game he had.
They just, Oh my God,
fucking captive, just snake.
But even when they had the guy beat,
even when they had them fucking beat,
they just couldn't get it on this day.
They was wide open and kicked the
fucking thing and I just couldn't do it.
They couldn't do it. But I have to say
right now, game seven, NHL playoffs,
I will put that up against any,
uh, any sport out there. Um,
the NHL playoffs, you
know, and I actually,
I actually totally missed the Edmonton
ducks one because I had to go and I had
to do a couple of shows and I thought
I taped the game and I fucked up.
I didn't someone have to go on the NHL
app today and Rewatch that game knowing
full well that the ducks won, which I
had a feeling they were going to do.
I just thought they had a
little more experienced.
They'd been there and that
type of shit. So yeah.
Um,
the fucking Josh, Jesus Christ, he was
just like, you know, by the end of it,
he was just like, you know what, fuck
this. He goes, I'm just going to stress,
eat a fucking large pizza and I'm
going to go home and watch cops.
Um, I dunno, having said that, I
still don't have confidence, you know,
with the Celtics and the wizards
I have, I have no idea. Like, uh,
this is a weird series. Um, it kind of
seems like the teams are gonna hold,
serve, you know, and hopefully that
happens and we'll win a game. Seven,
I have no idea. But just
watching like a DC sports fan,
it reminds me I beat,
I always have empathy for all of those
people cause that was my life right up
until basically 2004, I guess the Patriots
had already won one at that point.
But um, yeah,
that was kind of my life as a sports
fan for the longest fucking time.
Um,
yeah.
So my condolences to the
city of Washington DC still
got the wizard GNR out of
it. Congratulations to Pittsburgh. Oh,
this is going to kill me to say this.
Congratulations to Anaheim.
Whatever you are down there,
whatever that is, Orange County,
whatever the fuck that is down there.
I don't even, I don't even,
it's just one of the most soulless
fucking places I've ever made me know what
I'm judging the place. I always
drive down there, you know,
to do the Improv or whatever.
Um,
bought me hockey stuff down there. They
got fucking Disneyland's down there.
It's just, I don't know what it is.
It just looks like a giant movie set.
It doesn't look like I'm,
it's like when I went to San Jose and
they had that little mall area where they
had all that high end shit. They tried
to make it look vaguely fucking, I dunno,
European and you just like this.
This was clearly all built at the
same time and there's no history here.
I don't know what happened cause
I read a Steve Martin's book.
I'm born standing up I the
hardcover original version.
I loaned it to my neighbor and I never
got it back. What a fucking asshole.
That's still bugs me that I did that. Um,
but he was talking about how he grew up
in Orange County and riding his bicycle
to Disneyland past all the orange
groves and just the way he painted the
pictures, like, wow, that
sounded like a beautiful place.
And now you go down there
and it's just, you know,
one fucking strip mall after another.
I mean, it was getting hold. I mean,
human beings had done a
lot of unpretty, you know,
a lot of fucking lot unprotected
sex since then. And uh,
just kind of push the oranges out really
bill, is that what happened? I mean,
evidently,
evidently as far as I
can surmise. Um, anyway,
so I did two shows last night, did a
benefit at the laugh factory and I did a,
and I did the all things comedy
network show at, uh, the comedy store.
And I had also done a show Monday night
where I ran the whole hour and at the
risk of sounding like a
fucking bald, arrogant cont,
uh, the new hour is crushing
the man, a great time.
Somewhere in the,
during those Cleveland shows that put me
over the top and now I have confidence
that uh,
people aren't going to feel like they're
getting ripped off when they go to see
me. So, um, anyways, I dunno,
I got a bunch of fucking shit on my mind
cause I got to go down to the fucking
airport. I got to pick up some, I
gotta pick up the fee and we babies.
Um, oh by the way, my
apology to a MotoGP fence.
I didn't even know there was a race
this past week and I went on to my, uh,
my DVR or whatever the hell you call
it. And low and behold, there it is,
you know,
and the way my whole laugh just watches
whatever the hell she wants and now
deletes it. I didn't feel
like I had to include her now.
Like she likes motorcycle
racing or anything. So, um,
I believe they were in spanked.
I just sat there with my daughter and I
watched all three races back to back the
moto to the three in the fucking GP race
and they will all fucking great races.
You know, it's funny.
At first I didn't like moto three with
their little skinny bicycle tires.
Now I'm fucking into it. All three of
them were great races. The motto too,
I think the model two
was the one with the guy.
The guy in the lead fucking
just dumped the bike.
He fucked up coming out of a turn. Um,
and then the other guy was just
up to him not to blow it. And uh,
I don't know. I loved all of it and I'm
just watching the, uh, the MotoGP race.
All of a sudden it goes up towards,
I got thousand CCS. Valentino Rossi,
you haven't probably, Hey Nini, what's up?
How are you? I'm flailing over here.
I got like another 16 minutes to go and
I'm so stressed and I gotta go to the
fucking airport then I'm
all, I'm all over the map.
Um, Valentino Rossi, I was so
weird watching everybody pass him.
He had problems with like his tires.
This is why this guy's this shit.
He's been doing it for, he's been
doing it for so fucking long.
I even know who this guy is.
And he came in 10th place and
he's still in first place.
That's pretty God damn impressive.
This early into the season. And uh,
I kind of became a fan of that. Yohan,
Yohan Asarco I like the bike,
all black and he just was fucking
passing everybody. He ended up being,
I don't know what he finished like
fourth, maybe he's a French guy.
I like the French, you know, I
don't know, but I'm totally into it.
I don't know any of the fucking
names. I know mark my cares. Right.
That's it. I'm looking at all these
other, I've got 'em all a whole list here.
I could pretend like I know these
guys off the top of my head. I don't,
I have no idea, but one of these guys
are, but I will tell you, like, he,
I mean if you think racing is boring,
motorcycle racing is a good one to
start with because, uh, you know,
if you're not into racing, you want
to see some crashes and uh, you know,
motorcycle race exists.
I mean literally the guy he just imagined
with every fucking stock car race,
every time there was an accident,
the guy like flew out of the car.
Okay.
I mean I'm not sitting there saying
I want to see anybody get hurt.
But I mean it is riveting.
Yeah.
It's just fast. Like first of all,
the level of technology of the suit
that they can be going like 150 miles an
hour, lay the bike down.
You know, they lean too far.
They fucking hit their knee or some shit.
I don't know what happens is I've done
it. That handlebar hits the ground,
there's so low
and they causes the bike to slide out
from underneath them and then they go in
like whatever hundred 30 miles an hour,
just slide in and dig pop right back up.
Okay.
Cause the suits are
made out of space. Age.
You know, it was funny when I was, uh,
when I had my brief motorcycle riding
career out here in la before I smartened
up and realized that, uh, I'm not a
motorcycle guy. I am a fan, but I am.
I just,
I was riding scared and
everybody's texting and
something bad was gonna happen,
man. Um, I, uh,
I actually was going like trying to
think of how to protect myself and I was
thinking I was going to get either a
Ducati or I was going to get that Harley,
uh, that throwback seventies one. And uh,
I was gonna buy one of those MotoGP suits.
We'd probably gonna cost more than
the bike. I thought it would be.
Larry's just be riding a
Harley wearing a GP suit.
You look like he's supposed
to dress like, you know,
you used to be in a biker gang. There's
something about being on a Harley.
You have to wear like jeans.
It's like not acceptable to have the
leather on leather suit. Hello. Lovely.
Hello handsome. What's going on?
Another thing I was just going to say,
you know what's even more
boring than watching racing?
You just, you just don't
like it at all. Well,
listening to you talk about
racing, it's probably more boring.
Wow.
[inaudible]
like four hours. It feels like
there's a swarm of killer bees.
That's what it sounds like
does no. Like what, how,
why you're just, we're waiting
to watch the crash. Right. I was,
I was hearing you from the kitchen.
Did you like that's literally what
you're at. Cause it's so fucking boring.
Like that's the level to which like
the boredom you feel when you watch it.
Like you're waiting for an accident.
Like that's all your mind goes with
dark plays cause you're so bored.
You're like what is this? Someone
does like crash. No, no, no, no.
It's boring. God it's
boring. No, no I was,
I was saying when you first
sit down and watch it,
that's what you're hoping for. Cause
you don't understand what's going on.
But when you, once you start
on just hoping for that,
nobody's hoping for it when they watch it.
Is that why people watch what I'm
saying? If you're not into it,
that's why you would watch, she'd
be like, well I'll see an accident.
I mean nobody likes an accident.
Everybody like when they
see somebody changing,
a fucking tire will cause
four lanes of, you know,
traffic people going, oh is he
the car gonna fall on his head.
What's going on over there?
Yeah. The rubbernecking,
the most interesting part of the racing
now that I've watched with you is when
is it Lewis Hamilton?
He's the champion. Right?
He Know Nico Rosberg is the ferning
champion, but his wife told him, well,
now that you won the championship, it's
time for you to pay attention to me.
And he fucking retired.
Or he was like, oh,
I don't want to deal with Lewis again.
And he just left. Hmm. Well, anyway,
I'm here wasn't him that I stout
his team mate and they were like,
these two have it spoken
at over six months. Yeah.
It was like a whole days of thunder
thing last year that the dead or the day.
Yeah. There's all of that stuff goes
on. There's the pride of the country,
the Ferrari's, the Mercedes,
right. All of that shit.
And then once you get into
like the different tires,
when to pit the strategy of it and all
of that, it's amazing. And this year, um,
the adjustments that they've made
on the cars is way more passing.
I'll tell you last year was it was a
little boring where it's like, what was,
it was a race to the first turn.
Whoever got to their first just to held
that position for the rest of the race
because you couldn't
pass them. Wow. Riveting.
Well, listen, I'm going to go. All
right. She's crying. She's crying. Go,
go, go. I don't mean to
trash your your interests.
I just thought it'd be funny to come in.
You don't find it interesting with them
what those motorcycles go on that fast
like the balls at that takes
the fucking balls. I don't,
I don't find it
interesting. No doubt balls,
but not interesting. All right,
so you'd rather watch a bunch of balloon
tinted horse screaming at each other.
Yeah, near and Renee Hill. Everybody.
There you go. And that's why
that's there. Right there.
That is the fissure in our relationship.
That's the fault line right now.
You know what?
At some point we're going to talk about
the fact that you spend like hours
watching people fight each other on
Worldstar and all these other kind of
websites.
But then you want to come at me because
I watch real housewives and people are
arguing. Well,
they never get to the fight every time
they've already to fight a cameraman
breaks it up. If those women would
beat the shit out of each other,
I'd watch it. If you just sit there
and say mean shit to one another.
Well somebody dabs at
the rise with tissues.
It still bugs me to this day that that
white woman spitting fucking Miss New
York's face and they owed it to her.
They owed it to her to give her
a couple of fucking swings. Oh,
the way she did the about face,
like that was the end of it.
After she spit in somebody's face. True.
They should, uh, let her beat her ass.
Oh, there you go. That's why I
don't like reality TV pop off
all of them. Like she down
there just, it drives me nuts.
It's like you order to ignore reality
TV is, it's just like fucking,
it's like blue balls the whole time
he comes to fight, he comes to fight,
they're starting to swing. I bring
it up, break it up, break it up.
The tension just keeps building
and it never happens. It's like,
you know when there's a big
fucking UFC fight coming up, right?
Imagine if they just kept running the
promo and Joe Rogan just kept getting more
and more amped up about how great the
fight was going to be and then it never
happened. Right. As they went to
fight, Dana white comes out, hey,
there'll be enough of that.
That'll be enough for that.
And then you had to deal with the two
fighters fucking talking to the camera.
I just felt like for me, I wanted to
have a fight to decide it, but you know,
for me, all
right, I'm sorry. Let's,
let's read a little bit at that stead
is the number one fucking expression in
reality TV. I know I say it all
the time, nineties feeling for me.
For me. I just feel like for
me, that for me, I need to like,
I need to just do that, but
I am not doing it for her.
I'm doing it for me.
Um, all right. Let's, uh, let's
do a little bit of the, uh,
the reads here for the week.
All right. Give me Luke. Craig.
Everybody on a quest for epic gear.
Why all of a sudden this
does seem really loud.
They can actually move the button there.
Are you on the quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles? Lou Crate
has it. The best surprise, you know,
is coming.
Luke Craig offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're, um, if you're more
of a fanatical Fashionista,
then try Luke where I'd never know
what any of this shit is of what's a
fanatical fab fashion. He
says somebody into fashion.
Is that alliteration or as
fanatical a type of fashion.
Shut the fuck up and read a bill. Okay.
Monthly wearables and accessories
with cult classics and your favorite
franchises. If you want to get fancy,
it's fucking layers that say, hey,
you want to get fucking fancy, busy
Bailey baggy. Get a bigger box and
even bigger loop with Luke crate,
DX, bigger box C's. You ever
run into that problem? Wow.
Big fucking box. I can't fill this
up. Want to geek out your pet.
Try.
Luke pet's offer expires April 19th
at 9:00 PM Pacific Geek got your pet.
You just go. You want to go for a ride?
You want to go for a ride in the car
and said tale hitting the ground
in male inmates. Luke crate,
you'll find items from
guardians of the galaxy,
two star wars destiny and the Goonies
one lucky subscriber will also win a mega
crate including a premium format
group figure from sideshow,
collectibles that is over
22 and a half inches tall.
Somewhere out there. Somebody
getting excited by this. You have,
I feel like I'm reading
another language right now.
You haven't til the 19th at 9:00 PM
Pacific to subscribe and receive that
month's crate when the cutoff
happens. That's it. It's, oh,
go to Luke,
great.com/burn enter my code bird to save
$3 off on any new subscription today.
Okay. Then the next one, oh,
it's our old friends, old zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place. Oh, that
isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Do you want to find the perfect hire?
You need to post your job on all the top
job sites you got who are it out there
and now you can with those
ziprecruiter.com you can
post your job to 100 plus
job sites including social media networks
like the Facebook and the Twitter
[inaudible]
all with a single click. Find
candidates. Susan bloons, Dean crawling.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just want just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into old zip.
Yeah,
easy to use interface. No juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate them
and hire that person fast. Yeah,
you're going to work next to me.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has
been used by fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and
medium sized businesses.
And right now my listeners
can post jobs on zip.
Okay.
God, I wrote his bio for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/iceberg
that's ziprecruiter.com/
[inaudible] one more time.
Try It for free. Go to zip.
Okay.
Dot Com slash burb all right.
Aw, look. Who's he? Me On bs.
Me On ds. No more sweaty
balls to do to do me undies.
Me undies. Get him
before the fucking fall.
Jump on your motorcycle
slide across the track.
Gill Shits your pits and that is,
that's fucking out. Find it fell apart.
I was trying to get racing in there.
I'm sorry. Take two on the me undies.
Mandy's Mandy's riding a motor bike
to do two to me on these meanders.
My girl is straight. She's not up.
And then I get in trouble with gay
and lesbians. Fuck. Let's see. Uh,
the Andy, me undies.
Welcome. I did two nights to
do two to me on these munies.
My balls feel really right now.
I said soft right down there.
Is it underwear or a teddy bear?
They're this off this
underwear. I don't know.
There's only so many different ways
you can fucking sing it, right? Listen,
people elevate your underwear game
to the next level with me on these.
You perfected your wardrobe.
But what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see.
We're talking about your junk,
Aka your family back East
family down south. Um,
if you've been settling for store bought
underwear, five packs, I've noticed it.
Why? Why would you be
subtly for that? You know,
isn't it enough that some poor bastard
had to sell those things together and
then his fucking six month old had to
put them in that plastic bag so you could
fucking, you know, deal with
parking down at the grove.
I have something that will change your
life for the better. What is it? Oh,
it's old me undies.
What's the first thing you put on
in the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear, right?
Unless you, Matthew Mcconaughey,
make your first and most important piece
of clothing the best it can be with me
on these. What is me undies you may
have asked, oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your
door beyond. These are designed in La,
Los Angeles, Louisiana. We don't know,
and made from sustainably sourced
micro modal, modal of fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
Mandy's softer than socks, soft lugs,
undies, Lux,
z Luxy unders on these luxury undies
come in and ever changing selection of
classic colors, bold shades
and adventurous patterns.
You go girl,
you go with your softball so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style. And guess what? You can save time.
You can save money each month
with a monthly subscription.
If you're not ready for a subscription,
that's okay. You can still save.
That's because me unease is
offering 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL me
undies.com/bar and get 20% off your
first fucking pair. So go ahead,
revamp your underwear drawer. You
deserve it. Treat yourself. Once again,
that's me. undies.com/burr
bmds.com/bar evidently
Vladimir Putin wisdom
because she didn't know that he wears
it right. Alright, frame bridge.
Everybody. Do you have a thought?
Do you have a thousand photos living
in your phone and not a single one in a
frame?
Now you can get those great man memories
off your phone and on your wall with
frame bridge.com go to frame bridge.com
f r a m e bridge.com like a picture
frame and oh London
bridges, but it's only one.
By the way, the London Bridge
is not the tower bridge.
Everybody thinks to tower bridge is the
London Bridge. That's the tower bridge.
Alright?
The London Bridge is the London Bridge
and it looks like a fucking footpath that
you can drive a car across. Okay?
Just to just know that if you
ever go to London, all right,
choose your frame or let their
designers help you choose.
Upload your photo from your
computer or directly from Instagram.
Review your photo online in the frame
you choose can upload your photo art.
That would be me. Should you stab
your computer screen with your phone?
Don't do that. No worries.
You can mail it for free.
Free bridge uses premium
real wood moldings, acid free
mat board and foam board,
and the acrylic glazing
will never shatter.
It protects your peace
from harmful UV rays.
I love what they call your selfie a
piece like it's a fucking work of art
because you're doing the Yolo fucking
piece on the expert team at frame.
Bridge will custom frame
your item and 10 days,
not weeks or months and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang.
Don't get stuck searching for a last
minute gift or an out for mother's Day.
I'm just cause to say that's
perfect for mother's Day.
For Mother's Day delivery, go to frame
bridge.com and use the promo code bar.
Wait, but it takes your ted
days. Mother's Day is Sunday.
You'll save an additional
50% off your first order.
You just go to frame bridge.com Promo
Code per frame, bridge.com Promo Code Bar,
last one. Everybody see?
So you
see, so [inaudible] woo.
Every hair is something every or something
being a barrel of laughs or a barrel
might've been enough left in
the days of horses and buggies.
But you live in the now.
That's why CSOs library of standup
television and original content provides
streaming laps up to 1.7 mega barrels,
and that's proven by science.
All right, that's all real.
Sign up now to catch brand new standup
specials from the Great Nick Depaulo from
the formidable Joey Coco da
and the new season of the
wonderful big j o sins.
What's your fucking deal? Oh,
watch your favorite sets from comedians
like the Great Louis C K Amy fucking
show and Hannibal Buress
access CSO content from
anywhere at any time using Ios,
android, Roku, apple
TV, Amazon fire, Amazon.
Fire me out. TV windows
are X. Bought Xbox one.
Ready for the punchline. CSOs
just three 99 per month. No joke.
Less than four bucks per month
for all the comedy you want.
Anytime anywhere add free. Just go to CSO,
s e e s o Sierra, Echo, Echo Sierra,
oscar.com right now to sign up for one
month for free with Promo Code Bar at
checkout. That's seeso.com spelled CSO,
s e e s o.com Promo Code
[inaudible] dot com what the fuck?
Promocode Burch, Jesus Christ.
How many times can you say it?
How many times can you say it? All
right it, I gotta go to the airport.
I got to lose EOB and we age.
Um, thank you for listening.
And uh, oh, guess what the music's
going to be. This is the night game.
The one I was telling you about debut,
which is a band that he's
playing and playing a,
a sort of 80s pop thing
with the 2017 flare.
If I do say so myself, we're gonna
be getting all current low right.
And dive trooper telling you
guys that they were a great band.
I've been telling you guys that I saw
them live and have you been listening to
me? I don't know. Maybe you
have, maybe you have not.
But guess who just got one
of the opening slots slots?
Probably say slots on fucking
John May is a world tour.
The night game. I fucking called
it. I told you itself. Here you go.
Uh, I believe Andrew told me he's
going to be playing the night games.
I think this is, I'll
feel this song is, um,
we slide into the second half of this
podcast, which will be, I don't know,
Thursday from podcast
gone by. I have no idea.
This right here is why I got out of radio.
Ickes cannot intro his son to
save my fucking life anyways.
What I'm trying to say is he out? Um,
the night game outfields
coming up next and then after,
that's going to be some greatest hits.
A half hour of me running my Yap when
I was a little bit younger. All right.
Have a great weekend. You
cons. I'll talk to you later.
Yeah. Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Come true.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I don't know. He trusts a lot.
[inaudible] [inaudible] I can
either way talk under your breath.
[inaudible]
passive picking c with the
the only one.
Sometimes Sheila comes talking too much.
[inaudible]
yes. Got me in trouble with
fiance's family. Uh, hey there.
Billary Brrrum Clinton.
I'm I fucked up man.
As you can probably guess from the
subject line cue the o g a m as a little
background,
I'm getting married next month to my
fiance who was wonderful love of my life
and all that. We were visiting her family
last night and playing board games,
which we often do. Oh Jesus. [inaudible]
what happened? We had drinking.
Did you get competitive? Huh?
She accused her mom of cheating.
Uh, he goes, I'll spare you the details,
but we were playing a card game
with a bunch of characters.
Everyone gets the same people,
but when you use them is
really the key to the game.
There was a particularly powerful card I
had held onto until the very last stage
of the game. The character's
name was granny Wada,
um,
pronounced Gary water.
I gave you the pronunciation and accent
so you wouldn't fuck it up. Well,
it is spelled w a t a granny. Ah,
it's the last round of the game and
everyone's going around revealing their
card.
I was last and my plan had worked
perfectly as I went to reveal it,
my inner bill bird took over and I really
got excited. I flipped it over. Oh,
you did it? He goes, oh
no. Oh No. He goes, I said,
it's granny fucking
whoa.
Don't you drop the F pub? Oh my God,
I wish I had podcast tee
shirts. I'd send one to you.
Okay.
No, you did. He goes, silence
followed as an echo through the house.
My fiance's family were stunned.
They're not super uptight
people, but people just don't,
just don't throw fucks around
during a board game. You know?
From there it only got worse. My
fiance is listen to your podcast,
so she knows I was imitating you.
She tried to stammer out
an explanation. Oh No.
She had to explain away your behavior.
Ah, dude.
He goes, but it didn't really do anything.
I also tried to apologize sheepishly.
Then on top of that,
that move gave me enough points
to win the game over everyone,
so I had to awkwardly mark my
score, which made me the winner.
Wow, dude.
When you're getting married next month,
so the fucking taste of this is still
going to be in their mouth. He goes,
we left almost immediately after,
and of course I got yelled at all
the way home. I knew I deserved it,
so I didn't even put up much of a fight.
That's your first good move in
this story. Oh Wow. He goes,
my question is do I try and go out of
my way to remedy the situation or do I
just hope everyone forgets
about it and moves on?
We're getting married in six weeks,
so it's not like I can
avoid them for very long.
I'm pissed because I fucking
crushed the impression too.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
Sorry for the Hillary Clinton reference
in the open or I think she's a cunt to a
, I don't think she's a contractor.
Just don't think she's an honest person.
And I don't think just because of
the fact that we've never had a woman
president that that's reason enough to
elect someone is dishonest and as phony
as her. Um, anyways, though,
you know what? I would,
I would actually, uh, without your wife.
I would just drive over there and
just say, listen, I got to apologize.
I listened to this podcast.
I'm a big fan of the guy. Um,
I was making a joke and in the moment
I didn't realize that you guys didn't
listen to the podcast if you want.
And just Cav a cue up a
clip where you have it,
which might be a bad thing to do,
but like just have me
like save something else.
Dr cabbies, easy shave butter, but any
might be fuck cause I don't say fuck,
um, [inaudible]
just say, just tell him you're
really embarrassed or whatever.
I think if you went over
there by yourself, I think a,
especially her dad, because I
think that's the big one there.
I think there's, there's something
extra when it's, you know,
it's always extra, you know, when,
when you're getting married like a,
you know, if you're a
guy, you know, the, the,
the dad's going to be looking at you twice
as hard and the moms can be like, oh,
he's, no, it's relaxed, you know.
And then the other way around is if you
know they have a son and he brings a
woman around,
like the mother's going to be fucking
looking at her to see if she's a fucking,
you know, and evil little whore. You know,
the dad's going to be looking at you like,
is this guy going to be overbearing
and slap my fucking daughter around or
whatever. You know what I mean? I see
a piece of shit, right. Um, oh my God,
dude. Wow.
You said it's granny fucking water.
Oh God. Dude, if you film that, oh my God.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I got to give, I
got it. My tip of the cap for you there,
man, for doing that. Holy Shit.
I'm getting uncomfortable just thinking
about that. Well, can I, I'll apologize.
Can I apologize to your fiance
for being a bad fucking a
okay.
A bad, um, influence. Hey,
you know what? Play this to a,
play this to your year, your future
in-laws. Dear future in laws.
Hello, I'm bill burr. I'm the
one who says granny defin.
I say this type of stuff. I have been
the bad influence. Don't be mad at him.
I'm sure he's a wonderful human
being. I'm sorry you missed up.
He messed up your little
cad game there. Um, yeah,
he's gonna make a great
son in law. You know why?
Cause he uses Dr cabbies easy. Shane
don't play that to them. That's
not going to get yet anything.
Just can say he listens to
morons. He must be a moron.
Are they going to have half a moron?
[inaudible]
be like walking up.
[inaudible] it's gone.
It's still bar and a, this is
not the Monday morning podcast.
This is the replacement
for the podcasts that I fucking
made yesterday. That uh,
oh and I completed this.
I already tried to fucking do this
and I just been talking for fucking 20
minutes and I looked down
and I wasn't recording.
So this is actually the third
fucking time I'm trying to do this.
So I'm going to get right to the point
on what the fuck is going on in my life
right now. Uh, kind of like, you know,
when you break your arm or the
first time you tell the story,
you got every fucking detail, right?
Then the next time you tell it there's
a little less detail and then by the
fifth time you just pissed and you want
to smash your cast over the fucking
person who asked you, how'd you
break your arm dude? Y'All do?
What'd you do that for?
Did it hurt? All right,
this is what happened. I recorded
a podcast on Monday. All right.
And um,
I was actually really excited because
somebody sent me this really cool MP3 that
they had made where it
was an amalgam of, uh,
all the podcasts I'd done in the
background, you know, in the past. I mean,
you know, just made this really cool
like 92nd thing. So I was like, you know,
that's awesome.
This is going to be a great new thing
that I can add to the podcast. Right.
Start it off with my little 16 year old
chick flip flown, you know, cell phone,
those awful podcasts. And
I bought the Olympus ls 10.
Then I got a mixer and
a microphone, you know,
and you guys are probably sitting there
going, how the fuck can he take this to,
to an even higher level. There's no
way. And I was about ready to go.
Like, yeah, there is a
way you mother fuckers,
I'm going to fucking have MP3 of the
week and start having people send me in
these mp3s and I fucking
put it into garage.
I edited the whole thing in and I
turned it into a fucking MP three.
And for some reason g cast is not
taking it. I don't know what's going on,
but uh, you know, I'm sure it's
me, so always ends up being me.
So I'm going to figure out
how to do that. And uh,
in the meantime, I will
tell you a quick story.
This is only going to be
like a 20 minute podcast, um,
of what I'm dealing with to my
life right now. I, uh, I got a dog,
I'm just pausing right now waiting for
all the animal lovers out there to stop
going. Oh my God. So that's,
could it be so good for him? That
keys can be so good for him? Um, yeah,
it has been good. Um, except for,
you know, a number of things. Uh,
one I didn't pick out the
dog, I was on the road.
This is a typical female thing, you
know, her heart was in a good place.
She's like, you know,
he wants to get a dog.
He just doesn't know how to do it cause
he wasn't hugged or loved as a child.
So I know what I'm gonna do. I'm
gonna go, I go get a little fuzzy.
Why's he dog?
And I'm just going to have it here and
I'm going to surprise or whatever the
fuck she was thinking. Right.
So basically I'm on the road and it's
typical how women do shit like this.
Okay. I don't know what they
call it. Like a, you know,
a finagling manipulation, whatever the,
it's whatever the euphemism is.
It's, they lie to you, you know,
and they tell you in bits and pieces,
what the fuck is really going on?
This is, this is how she did it. She
left a message and she said, hey honey,
it's knee. Um, I did something
and it involves both of us. Um,
but don't worry, I think you're gonna
like it actually. You're gonna love it.
You're gonna love it. Just call
me. I'll tell you what it is. Okay.
By click right. Call her
up. And she says, listen,
a friend of a friend of mine has a dog
and she needs us to watch it for a week.
And I was like, perfect. That is awesome.
I'm a commitment phobe one week, you know,
that works perfectly for me.
So, uh, I go, yeah, fuck it.
Let's get it right. And
she goes, great. Awesome.
Great to only be here for a week, you
know, I'm like, cool. Next phone call.
Yeah. So anyways, I got the dog. She's
so cute. Above, above, above, uh,
yeah. And we keep it for a week
and at the end of the week,
if we want to keep it, we
can have it. And if not,
they take it to a shelter and it gets
put down. And I'm like, what? What? Wait,
wait, what? You just got us a dog, right?
She got a rescue dog.
The exact thing I've been making fun of
in my act that the joke I did on Conan
that got me all that mail from
all the dog lovers. And uh,
not only that, it's a pit
bull. Isn't that great? Huh?
I'm just waiting for it to be like, dude,
what do you, how do you fucking mind?
He already fuck them out.
Fucking two hoes fucking dogs to,
I'm trying to fuck a loyal dude,
but I'm telling you one day you
look the other way. They did.
They just fucking snap too. One time I
heard about this guy, there was this guy,
right? [inaudible]. There was this
guy and he got a pit bull, right?
There was this guy and he
had a pit bull shut up.
So anyways,
we've got this fucking pit
bull and evidently they
found it down by the La River
and a, yeah, it's a fucking awesome dog.
I can't even, I can't even lie to you.
It's a fucking great dog. It's a scary
looking dog. I'm not gonna lie to you.
It looks like it wasn't by the La
River was more by the fucking river.
Haiti's it's definitely looks like a hell
hound, but it is a fucking sweetheart.
And uh, you know, by the second
day, I love the thing. I'm like,
fuck this. We're keeping it. I
loved it. I walk it down the street,
people cross the street. It's great.
It's fucking great. So Kevin, a gun that,
that you can pet.
It's a fucking awesome dog.
And uh, you know, I've had
other dogs have charged it.
It hasn't freaked out yet. You know,
it's gonna Freak out to fucking time.
Bomb them out of my mind. I
should give this dog back.
I'm out of my fucking mind. This,
you just know there's a
lawsuit at the end of this.
The only way it ends with a pit bull.
It ends with a lawsuit in a missing limb
in a second cousin that never talks to
you again.
And the only time you see him is when he
drives down the street and his fucking
customer,
El Camino that he bought with the 50
grand you gave him and he gives you the
finger. He takes his one
arm off the steering wheel,
gives you the fucking finger and continues
on down the street and his lime green
fucking Elderado. Um, anyways,
so this dog is this shit.
I love having an around.
I fucking love this dog.
She's awesome and I want to keep
it, but this is the problem. Um,
when we leave, it fucks up
the apartment or it has twice.
It scratched the door and it's
scratched something else in the back.
And it's like, dude, I
don't own this place. Okay,
I have a deposit. Do you understand that?
And one day the landlord's going
to come over to me and be like,
what the fuck is that?
And then I'm going to point at
you and you don't have a wallet.
And not only do you not have a wallet,
you don't have, you don't have money,
you don't have any money.
All right? You dumb fuck.
Which means it's coming
out of my deposit. Okay.
And that's what I've dealt with on
the last week is literally watching my
deposit slowly disappearing. You know,
you ever been up like two grand
playing blackjack, you know,
and you just sit in there like
it's never gonna end, you know,
and your buddies like dope,
dope. We'll walk away dude.
I'm telling you kick you up to a
grandkid walkway, do sweet money.
It's free money. Right.
And he keep fucking sitting there and
the horrors coming over there with the
whiskey and you keep drinking. Right.
Then some vacuum cleaner salesman sits
down and starts hitting on 17 and you
start doing that dumb shit
going dude, that was my car.
Cause you guys taken all my cards. You
know like if that fuck wasn't there,
you would continue to when you wouldn't.
All right do the fucking math.
How do you think they keep the lights on
all day long with the air conditioning
on and the fucking doors open in the
middle of the desert and they still can
afford to do it. Cause dumb fucks.
Like you sit there and
the longer you sit there,
it's simple fucking math
dude. I got it. System.
Um, so anyways, so I was like, listen,
I have, we, I'll, I'll keep the dog,
but we gotta put this thing in a
fucking cage when we go to leave. Okay.
So I go over to Petco. Okay. And um,
I didn't want to go there. There
was a local pet store. You know me,
I want to go to the mom and pop
store, but my girls just like, oh,
it's right around the corner. Everywhere
I work. Yeah, they got all this,
you know, they start doing that shit
and you just feel all the fucking,
you literally feel the fucking energy
draining out of your legs. You just like,
all right, we'll go where
you want to go. Right.
And then they do this shit. Well, she
said, if you don't want to go there,
we're good. No, forget it. We'll go there.
I don't know why you have to get mad.
I'm like, well, if you just fucking,
why do you ask me where I want to go?
If you already know where we want to go
and you were going to go there anyways.
Why do you put me through
that fucking test?
It's like fucking verbal
waterboarding. It's brutal. So anyways,
so we go over to fucking PETCO
and it's a typical corporation.
It's 90,000 square feet and they got
two people on the floor. All right.
And there's literally like,
people are gathered around the one person
with the fucking apron that's the same
color as the sign outside. So you like,
obviously they work here cause they
have a fucking apron that matches.
It's the same color.
Blue is the fucking sign.
And there's literally people gathered
around this person, like they're famous,
like they're waiting for an autograph
when the reality is is they're trying to
find a fucking flea collar and this
fucking Goddamn mega church that they have
for fucking dogs, right? Jesus Christ.
I almost fucking spun out of control
with all the references here anyways,
and we plow ahead here. Was that even
remotely funny? Anyways, let's go.
So anyways, get to the
point bill. So I'm fucking,
they said the guy's like,
all right, I go, listen,
I need I gotta I gotta I
got a fucking pit bull.
Evidently it's a pit bull mixed,
but I think it's mixed with another pit
bull cause it fucking looks like a pit
bull to me. The guy's like, hey
sir, don't worry, I'm gonna,
I'm going to be over there just about
10 minutes. Don't worry about it.
So I say fine. And I stand over there
for about seven minutes and I'm like,
you know what? This dude's not fucking
showing up. He's not fucking showing up.
So I just grabbed the biggest fucking
cage I can find cause I want it to be nice
and Roomy, you know, be a responsible
pet owner. I don't want to be cruel.
I don't wanna act like a fucking puppy
mill. You know, fuck a thing's huge.
You could fit a fucking Jacuzzi in the
corner. All right, it's a big cage.
So I bring the thing home,
air dam. Lo and behold,
a buddy of mine calls me up, says,
tells me he's got a Gig back
east for the whole summer
directing a bunch of actors
and some bullshit. So He's,
he's having a Gig and he wants me to
come by and say goodbye. So I say,
absolutely. My girl's not around. So I
go, I fucking stick the dog in the cage.
All right? And I feel awful. The dog
standing there shaking like a leaf.
I literally get the
thing to go in the cage.
It's facing the back of the
cage and it's not moving.
It's just standing there
shaking like you know,
like it knows a fucking earthquake
is coming or something. Okay.
So I'm sitting there trying to
convey to the dog like, dude,
I know you scared right now. You
know, I know you were abandoned,
but I'm not going to abandon
you. Do you understand?
You're just fucking up my
apartment and I can't have that.
So how do you say that? And how do,
how would the dog whisper convey that?
You know, I don't know how to do it.
All right dude. Um, I'm coming back.
Notice I'm leaving and I'm not
bringing you with me in the cage.
I could see if I was doing that.
I could see then you've fucking do it.
Just stop shaking it right. You know
that if you feel awful, stop, please,
please stop shaking. So I leave,
I go to the party in the
party for two fucking hours.
All I can think about as a goddamn dog
being scared in the cage and it's killing
me. It's ripping my heart out. So
I'm following. It's like, dude,
I got to get out of here.
I got this dog. I can't,
I can't fucking leave it alone. It's
killing me. So I fucking drive back
and I'm taking all this dogs and
be self psych to see me. You know,
that's the best thing when you
come home, when you have a dog,
the dog is fucking psych to see it, right?
So I come home and I opened the door and
who's fucking sitting on the other side
of the door is the God damn dog
just sitting there wagging its tail,
thumping it on the floor, you know,
completely, you know, normal look on his
face like, hey bill, what's going on?
You want an egg? You know, stick
it about making a lake breakfast.
What'd you get into tonight?
Height. And you get some pussy.
What's going on with you and you?
I've just fucking regular and
I'm looking at the dog like,
did I dream that I did? I not put
you in a fucking cage. The fuck is,
you know what the fuck
is going on here? Right.
So I walk out to the kitchen and I
don't know how to describe this without
pictures.
The only way I can describe it is it
looked like the cage got raped and then
thrown in front of a locomotive.
The fuck was like, it
was lopsided. It was,
there was a big chunk
taken out of the side.
And then there was these all
this blood on the floor. And um,
I was beside myself. I was,
I couldn't believe it. And I,
I want to say that the
cage door was still closed.
She just, she just fucked this thing up.
And now I'm sitting there freaking out
going, oh my God, she hurt herself.
There's blood all over the goddamn
floor, the amount of blood on the floor.
I would have thought that she'd
be laying there unconscious.
And she just sitting
there looking at me wagon,
his fucking tail on the Goddamn
linoleum now. So I, you know,
I'm looking at its mouth and there's
nothing in there. There's a little bit,
it's like one of the fucking x-men.
What's that extra. And you know, you,
you cut it and just automatically
heals. That's what it looks like.
It's just completely fine. So
I didn't, I don't know. I was
like, I was like half. Yeah,
I was definitely bummed cause I
was out a couple hundred bucks,
especially with all the fucking fuzzy,
let's make this cage a home
shit that I bought to put in it,
but a part of me respected it. I was
like, God damn, this is a fucking dog,
you know? And uh, I was like, all right.
Evidently I bought the wrong
fucking cage. So Jesus Christ,
I don't even know any more than
fucking two days later. Right.
I haven't left the house. We haven't
left the house and left her alone.
We keep bringing her in the, in the
Goddamn car. And that's another thing.
Bring in the car. She fucking stands
there. She shaking like, Oh fuck.
What did I do this time, man? I'm getting
a bandaid again with the fuck man.
You know, we're like, dude,
we're not abandoning you.
We just fucking relax and stick
your face out the fucking window.
Like a regular dog. Jesus Christ you,
you know, you're making me nervous,
you know? So finally we're like,
look, we need to have a life. Okay.
You know, I have to go out and do stand
up. You have to be able to go work.
I have to have, you know,
we got to get another cage.
So I finally go to Petco again and I find
one of those douchebags with the Blue
Apron or whatever and I go listen to
actually brought the dog. I'm like,
this is what I have.
This is what I bought and this
is what the fuck it did to it.
Do you have anything to help me? Okay.
The guys are like, yeah, no problem.
No problem. A,
it was all dealt well that we get one
of those wire cages and we'll get it a
muzzle. Cause that was a big
thing with me. I was like,
I don't want the dog to get hurt
trying to get out of the cage.
I want a cage that can't break out of and
I want to leave the dog in a situation
where it can't get hurt. So it gives me,
it gives me this muscle to put
on the dog where can still drink,
relax you fucking animal on loving
jackasses. It can still drink.
Okay. It could vomit if it had to. So
it's not going to die like John Bonam,
you know, a lot of people don't know that.
Not only did he have
32 shots of vodka, he,
they actually found him slumped
over in a doggy cage. All right. Um,
face down in a fucking water dish.
Okay.
All right.
I can't believe I just said that about
one of the guys I love the most anyways.
Um, so we get all the shit. I
get the fucking cage. All right.
And this time we're doing
like dog whisperer shit.
So literally an hour last
night we work with this doc.
We walked the dog by the cage,
we walked it back past the cage,
you know, and it's freaking out looking
at the cage and the cage has two doors.
So I got my girls got both doors open so
she's got half a body in the cage going
can make Cleo comedically. Oh good girl.
And she would sort of come close to the
cage and put her head down and wouldn't
go in it.
And then we'd walk away and we just
over and over and over and then one half
hour into it, nothing but
positive reinforcement.
All of a sudden it was like magic. It's
like a fucking afterschool special.
She just crawled, walked, you know,
like a little fucking marine
trying to go underneath barbwire,
went into the cage and we will like
that's a good girl, we will pet in it.
And you know,
my girl rubbed its head
till it fell asleep a little
bit and then when it got up
and wanted to get out of the cage,
we let it get out of the cage just
so it had that vibe, you know,
like this is your home, this
is, you're not being punished.
So then we do that exercise a
number of times. Another five, six,
seven fucking times. Kept walking
into the cage, praising it,
telling it was a good girl scratching it.
And then when I wanted
to get out of the cage,
we let it out of the cage right down the
fucking dog whispering numbers on how
to do this shit. So the
end of the night comes,
we slide this big mother
fucking cage. Okay.
Um, at the foot of the bed, she likes
to sleep on the foot of the bed.
We take the two pillows that she likes
to sleep on, we put them in the cage,
we put her in there and uh,
and we closed the cage and
she's sitting there and uh,
we caught out the lights
and then she just,
she whined sort of panted
in wine for like two hours.
Just gone. Just like that.
I couldn't believe we didn't pass out.
That's how quickly he was breathing.
Literally. Is that annoying to listen
to if you're on a plane right now?
That's what the fuck that thing did
for two hours to the point. I was like,
Jesus Christ in here. Let's just let
the thing out of the fucking cage.
And she's like, no. If we do that,
then it's gonna learn that that's all
it has to do is that annoying sound,
which I won't do again to fucking make
you guys fucking teeth hurt, you know?
So anyways, she finally
ends up going to sleep.
We go to sleep the next morning, she
wakes up, we let her out of the cage,
he's all excited. And I've been doing
what I've been doing with this dog.
I fucking run it up a god Damn Mountain
and I've run it right back down.
You know, fucking thing is all
muscle. It's the shit, right?
Fucking dog is awesome. Um,
so anyways, no roids either.
This is all natural. So anyways,
so today I get up and uh,
my beautiful girls got to go to
work and I had a meeting, you know,
trying to come up with a show idea,
trying to get a show on the air,
trying to come up with a better idea
so it won't get squashed like a bug,
like a,
my last fucking idea did right at the
last second when I thought I was home
free, you know,
gliding along free as a bird than
smash right into fucking windshield.
That's what I have my last idea. But
we, that's a whole nother podcast.
We won't get into that
shit. So anyways, we uh,
bring the dog, the cage.
She's definitely don't put the muzzle on
it so it won't hurt itself if it tries
to get out, which we know it's going
to try to, I put it's water in there.
We close the door,
we tell it to just tell her she's a
good girl and a, we saw it, you know,
I went out did, you know,
had my breakfast out in the kitchen and
I kind of peaked in the bedroom and it
was laying down.
The muzzle on thing was
totally cool and I thought,
I thought everything's great. This is
awesome. We have our lives back. You know,
I like to,
I gotta be able to do stand up and I
like to play drums in that type of shit.
I like doing that shit during the day
when I fucking can't stare at the walls
anymore.
So a off we go into the wild blue yonder,
I dropped my girl off at
work, I go and I, you know,
hanging out with this other comic,
we're trying to come up with the TV
show idea and I actually brought my shit
along with me cause I'm feeling free.
I can go play drums. The dog is cool.
And I was actually thinking
halfway through, right?
Just like when I was at the parties
like, Oh man, I gotta get home, man.
I feel bad. The dogs in the
cage. I fucking love that dog.
I fucking love that dog. I got to let
the dog out of the cage. I'll hang out.
You know, I'll play some guitar and
stead right then I'll watch the Bruins.
Hopefully beat the fucking hurricanes
tonight and game six, right? That's,
that was my game plan. And uh,
so I come home like this dogs and be
so fucking psyched on it, you know,
and I show up, let it out of the
cage. It's going to be flipping out,
jumping all around. It's
awesome. It's awesome.
When you come home and you got
a dog, right? So I come home,
I open the back door and
then we had this other doors,
got this big glass window and I go to
put the key in and I looked down and who
the fuck is sitting there?
Right on the other side of the door
just sitting there wagging its tail.
The fucking Goddamn Cleo. And
I'm looking at the dog going,
are you fucking shitting
me? And I look at its face.
It's got a little bit of dried blood on
its muzzle and right by its eye and it's
happy as shit. It doesn't give a fuck.
It's just wagging his tail. Hey Bill,
how was your meeting? You know, did
you come up with any ideas? You know,
don't give up man. I'm telling you,
you're going to get a TV show idea.
You want to go for a jog, right?
And I'm sitting here looking at
this fucking thing like, dude,
you gotta be shitting me. You
got to be fucking kidding me.
And I walk into the bedroom and here is
this fucking cage that this Douche bag
down at Petco said I would
be fine. Oh by the way,
the fucking thing still has
the muzzle, but it's off.
It got it off and it's hanging down
around its fucking neck. Like a Bandanna,
like some douchebag in prince's
band way back in the day.
Remember that guy who played
the fucking guitar keyboard?
The guy in the revolution,
prince and the revolution, right?
That's the way the muzzle is.
All I needed to be was like some sort
of fucking neon leopard print and that
thing was good to go. Right.
So I come walking in and I can't even
describe to you how fucked up this cage
was. And there was blood all over
the fucking floor. And once again,
I'm checking her mouth.
I'm checking her paws.
There are areas where there's
sort of dried blood on her fur,
but she's not bleeding. This dog is,
is not from this planet, but this cage is,
and you know, I took a fucking picture
of it. I should put it up on my,
on my myspace page. This,
yeah. I don't know what it did.
I don't know if it just fucking started
jumping up and down and slam it into the
sides of it. But this,
I'm looking at it right now. I can't,
there's like metal is just twisted
around. It's, it's wreckage.
That's what the fuck I have. It looks
like the rest of the cage is fine.
It looks like this. The front of the
cage had a front end fucking collision
with another car. I, so I don't know
what I'm going to do. People I have,
I have a situation because you
know I'm all for rescue on a dog,
but I didn't sign up for this shit and
I've blown over $300 in cages and I've
used both of them once
and this dog fucks him up.
And you know, I'm telling you,
you can't talk to animal lovers because
they're fucking crazy because they will
tell you anything just to get
you to keep the fucking dog,
you know? Oh it's just
because it's scared.
It's scared that it's
going to be abandoned.
You have to build up the
trust and it's like, you know,
that's not my fucking problem. I
want to keep this dot. But what the,
what the fuck am I supposed to do? Okay,
so there's my a, this isn't a podcast,
this is just me telling you why. Well,
I guess this has no reason to do why
there was no podcast. There's no podcast.
Cause I couldn't figure out how to go
from garage band to g cast and make it
work. So if you can help me with that.
And if somebody out there has rescued
a fucking pit bull and has gone through
this shit and they somehow
figured out how to get the dog
to, to be cool in a cage
because, uh, not only is
it cost me a lot of money,
this dog is injuring itself
and it's fucking killing me.
So if you can help me out,
I would appreciate it. Uh,
and that is it. That is,
this is a very special
Monday morning podcast done on a
Tuesday. I actually have a cause. Okay.
Oh, by the way,
if you've got any new mp3s or any type
of shit that you want to send me, uh,
you know, go ahead and send them.
I don't know. You know what?
Don't send it to me yet.
Just wait til I get my first one up there
that I understand how to fucking know.
If you know how to do it,
please let me know. That is it.
I hope all you guys have a good week and
hope I have some good news for the next
week. All right, dude. Bye
Daddy. Say, dude. All right.
And you'll see what I mean beside myself.
Alright, bye
[inaudible].